[Music]
over the past few years there has been a
horrible news story that keeps coming up
and um every time i see it i feel
overwhelmed but then last night i saw a
commercial that lets me know i'm not
alone take a look
and after that i raked all the leaves
painted the upstairs bathroom and then
taught a zumba glass
wow i guess i didn't realize my neighbor
was the energizer bunny
i feel like i have less and less energy
every day but you
you seem like you have an endless amount
of gas in your tank you have got to tell
me your secret are you sure you want to
know absolutely
my secret is
r kelly
what my secret is r kelly or rather my
hate for him are kelly the old r b
singer yes that's right when i saw that
documentary about him and heard those
terrible stories from a seemingly
unending list of women i was floored the
fact that that piece of [ __ ] got away
with decades of abuse lit a fire in me
that can never be put out and every day
i think about just the tiniest detail of
his crimes and
it fuels me
wow
is that how you stay so thin yes i no
longer require food my hate nourishes me
every morning i zip through the house
and clean it from top to bottom
my body generates so much heat that we
save in electricity bills wow i haven't
put gas in the car in forever really
nope i just push it around
how can i get some of that hate it's
simple
all you have to do is realize the
enormity of what that rancid bag of piss
did and all the ways in which people
helped him and then realized that some
of those people are still on his side
whoa whoa whoa you have to learn how to
control it
wow
i guess i got carried away
i feel full of energy
it's a dark energy i never had before
like i could murder a man with my bare
hands but also
i could take up jazzercise that's it
you've got it thanks neighbor and if
your energy ever starts to dip remember
most of us listen to his music long
after the allegations began so some of
the hate you're feeling is for yourself
are you sure i'll never run out of
energy i promise because the act of
propping up men who hurt people is
disturbingly common just google woody
allen harvey weinstein or the phrase
catholic priest whoa
is it hot in here or is it just my hate
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's your hate
[Applause]
[Music]
you